america often presents itself
to its own people but just the leaders
when they look in the mirror is
i get a sense that we think of ourselves
as the good guys
uh in especially this
begins sometimes to look hypocritical
when you're waging more
is what's a good um is there a good way
to know
when you've lost all sense of what it is
to be good um
another way to ask that is there in
military policy in conducting war
is there a good way to know what is a
just war
and uh what is a war crime i mean
in some circles kissinger is accused of
contributing
you know being a war criminal yes i i
and and i argue in the book he's not a
war criminal but that doesn't mean that
um
he didn't misuse military power um i
i think um a just war
war just war as michael walls and others
write about it a just war
is a war where both the purpose is just
and you are using the means to get to
that purpose
that uh kill as few people as
necessary that doesn't mean they won't
be killing but as few as necessary
proportionality
right your your means should be
proportional to your ends
and um that's often lost sight of
because the drive to get to the end
often self-justifies means that go well
beyond that and so that's that's that's
how we get into torture in the war on
terror
is there some kind of lesson for the
future
yes you can take away from that yes i
think the the the first set of lessons
that i've shared as a historian with
with military decision makers is first
of all always remember
why you're there what your purpose is
and always ask yourself if the means
you're using
are actually proportional ask that
question just because you have these
means that you can use just because you
have these tools
doesn't mean they're the right tools to
use and here's the
question that follows from that and it's
a it's a hard question to ask because
the answer is one we often don't like to
hear
are the things i'm doing in war actually
doing more harm or more good
to the reason i went into war we came to
a point in the war on terror
where what we were doing was actually
creating more terrorists
and that's when you have to stop
well some of that is in the data but
some of it there's a leap of faith
so from a parenting perspective let me
let me speak as a person with no kids in
the same
single guy let me be the expert in the
room i'm parenting
no uh it does seem
that it's a very difficult thing to do
to um
even though you know that your
kid was making a mistake to let them
make a mistake to give them the freedom
to make the mistakes
sure i don't know what to do but
i mean that's a very kind of
light-hearted way of phrasing
the following which is when you look at
some of the
places in the world like afghanistan
which is
not doing well right to move out
knowing that there's going to be a lot
of suffering
economic suffering injustices
terrorist organizations growing that
committing crimes on its own people and
potentially committing crimes
against allies violence against allies
violence against the united states
um how do you know what to do in that
case well
again it's an art not a science which is
what makes it hard for you know an
engineer to
to think about this is what what makes
it endlessly fascinating for me yeah
and i think the real intellectual work
is at the level of the art
right and i think probably engineering
at its highest level becomes an art
as well right so policy making you never
you never know
um but i will say this i'll say you have
to ask yourself and look in the mirror
and say
is all the effort i'm putting in
actually making this better
and in afghanistan you look at the 20
years and
two plus trillion dollars that the u.s
has put in
and the fact that as you said correctly
it's not doing well right now after 20
years of that investment
you know i might like a company that i
invest in but after 20 years of my
throwing money in that company
you know it's time to get out well in
some sense getting out now
is um that's kind of obvious i'm more
interested in how we figure out
in the future how to get out earlier
then i mean at this point
we stayed too long and it's obvious the
data the the investment
nothing is working you know it's very
the very little data points to us
is staying there i'm more interested in
uh
you know being in a relation let me back
take it back to a safer place again
being in a relationship and getting out
of that relationship while things are
still good but you have a sense that
it's not going to end up in a good place
that's that's the difficult thing you
have to ask yourself
whether it's a relationship or you're
talking about policy making in a place
like afghanistan
are the things i'm doing showing me
evidence real evidence that they're
making things better
or making things worse that's a hard
question to be honest with you you have
to be very honest and in a policy making
context
we have to actually do the same thing we
do in a relationship context what do we
do in relationship context we ask
other friends who are observing right we
ask for other observers this is actually
just a scientific method element
actually right
that we can't the heisenberg principle i
i can't see it because i'm too close to
it i'm changing it
by my looking at it right i need others
to tell me in a policy making context
this is why you need to hear from other
people not just the generals because
here's the thing about the generals
they're they generally are patriotic
hard-working people but they're too
close
they're not lying they're too close they
always think they can do better
you